you
thank you
we're going to be having only hearings
today we're not going to be doing any
any executive sessions so let's start
off uh
representative yokela you would like to
introduce the bill
before you do that i'm gonna ask the
kirk the clerk to take attendance
thank you mr chairman uh chairman dolan
yeah
vice chairman pierre monte
clerk is here
representative
tripp representative president okay
representative guthrie
representative los alas here
representative mcbride
representative melvin
representative here
representative power here
representative
representative gilman
here
representative majori here
representatives davis
okay thank you
uh representative klee here
representative gallagher
here
and representative run here
thank you
uh representative
uh
floor is yours
thank you mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee
um
for the record my name is representative
joshua keller i represent rockingham
uh 33 fremont danville and brentwood and
today i'm introducing hb 1136
i'm just requiring planning boards to
list the type of studies that would be
required to render a decision
there are requirements to
you know post the fee schedule for
for planning
and uh zoning
uh
fees that would be applicable to
applications
in the hopes of allowing people to
be able to predict what the cost of
their application is going to be so that
they can plan accordingly
and
i see that this is just
one piece of that so that they can
be able to predict better what
what their uh
expenses for for their application is
going to be
you know the range of possibilities
as far as that expenses depending on
which which
studies that are listed would be
required for them
and also um
allow that they
that they wouldn't be required to
repeat the exact same study
multiple times because that would
obviously increase the
the cost of it
um a cost of the application
obviously obviously the um
if a
change was made to the um
the thing that was studied then
obviously
that
that wouldn't be
uh
an issue if it needed to be re-studied
you know if you study the water
um
drainage issue and then you make a
change to the drainage
um it it makes sense that this that the
um
the board would be able to
require a new study with that new
information but not if you didn't make a
change to the drainage and they would
just want to get it try and get a
different answer from that study
that's kind of the
the goal of this bill and i'm happy to
answer any questions
thank you
before we get started with that
just for the record we've had two people
are registered for this bill
one four and one against
so uh does the committee have questions
for the representative
yes uh representative gallagher
hi um
i'm wondering if
um you could provide us with a bit more
uh specificity about how
repetitive is designed here like how are
interpreters of this law supposed to
decide whether a study is repetitive or
not
thank you for that question
so in the in the bill it says
um
so
repetitive studies so it wouldn't be you
would be studying the same thing again
it would not be allowed unless there was
a change to the plan
after the study's completion which
substantially impact the issue studied
so
if you study drainage and then you
change the drainage of the plan then
the board would be able to ask you to
restudy that
drainage
impact on the on the plan but if
let's say you
you study
the soil
samples
for you know wetlands
impact or or or um
maybe a better example is uh traffic
study if you did a traffic study
on
on your uh
your plan
because you're you know building a
development of 10 houses or something
and you want to be able to find out
what's what's the impact on the roads
going to be and then you train change
the drainage you shouldn't really really
have to restudy the
the traffic study again because
changing drainage doesn't really
affect
the change of the traffic right so that
was kind of the um
the wording and and how i think it would
be handled in practice and then uh i
think that um the
the board would take a vote on whether
they believe
that
um
the change substantially impacted the
issue studied
and obviously any
ruling of the board would be able to be
appealed to the zba
and the zba would be the
place if there was a disagreement
between the applicant and the board so
that that could be resolved
thank you for the question
representative
um good morning uh representative and
thank you for taking my question i have
a number of questions about this bill as
a member of a planning board yes for a
relatively large municipality
first
can you tell me where the title of the
bill
dilatory studies comes from because it's
nowhere in the statute
so i i didn't write the title of the um
the uh
the section so let me
just
i would have to look that up for you
well
but more importantly
um my question is
speaks to
the meaning of the word dilatory in this
context has a negative connotation when
in fact many planning boards
in the course of reviewing
projects must
do multiple tests on the same issue
and part of their due diligence process
i also i have a question about your
mention in your introduction of the bill
about
listing fees
for uh applicants and i don't see that
anywhere in your bill
no that's currently required
it wouldn't be changed that's correct
but you mentioned it in your
introduction of the bill which made me
think that there would be additional
language concerning fees
thank you for the question
um so
the cost of
my point in in mentioning it in my
introduction was that the cost of the
studies
are part of the cost of that application
and so currently there are there are
requirements to
post the fees for the application
right
and so
in a sense all this is doing is saying
we understand that we're supposed to
post the fees for the application
and
some part of that cost
could be studies
and therefore we're going to also
let you know that these studies may
occur obviously the size and the scope
of the study will affect the cost but
being aware that they
that these are part of that process or
they could be part of that process would
help them understand whether or not uh
the total scope and cost of the project
as far as the application
thank you mr chair
follow-up mr chair yes
please thank you mr chair
uh
you also
said in response to the previous
question
that if a planning board if this bill
bill were to come law
wanted to do another study on us on the
same issue that it would there would
have to be a vote
taken by the board but i don't see that
in your bill
so
thank you for the question um so if you
wanted to do a traffic study
and then the board wanted to do another
traffic study
um they would have to decide
whether or not they are allowed to do
that
right
under this law
and
that discussion
that discussion about whether or not
they're allowed to do it
would be
up to the
they would vote on whether they believed
it would substantial if the study
um
if they're allowed to do it because the
plan substantially
uh changed the impact of the issue that
was studied
so if you come to the board you study um
uh
the traffic study and then you add 10
more houses
and then you could
you the the board could would say hey
maybe we want to study this traffic
study again because there's more houses
the chan plan has changed there's going
to be more traffic and so we want to
know what that impact is
right
the board would say okay we um
according to this law
we read it to
uh
substantially impact that issue and they
would make a ruling about whether they
believed that was
was impacted whereas maybe adding one
house
the board would say
it's um you know the one more car
would would not be substantial
substantially different than the
information that we got from the first
traffic study
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
i'm trying to understand if this is
a solution looking for a problem
can you cite how
can you cite any specific situations
that brought you to draft this bill
um
so thank you for the question um
so
i would obviously i'm i only live in one
town so it would only be relevant to
the my experience in my own town it
wouldn't be
you know a larger study of
how how uh
much this impacts people in other towns
it would be anecdotal anything that i
said
but um there was
um
something in in
the town
that i live in
that
was
controversial
um in the town and some of the people on
the board
were not
um
satisfied or did not like the person
that was chosen to do the study
um they did not like the answer of the
study is kind of how it how what came
about it and they wanted to look into
that issue again to try and get what
they thought was the correct answer and
so it's just trying to
make
in in that example
the the people
were trying i think to
kill the project by just studying it to
death
but
i think in general
you know it's important to be upfront
with what the
the fees are of the process and that's
why we have it required now
so i'm just trying to expand on that
representative
thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question absolutely so in
preparation for this bill hearing i did
two things
i um referenced rsa 674
and um that lists provisions um a
through e to which you would like to add
f as
outlined or in within the framework of
this bill and secondly
i looked up
for my town the site plan regulations
and i noticed on page seven my
particular town in fact does list
studies for example environmental impact
hydrological impact ground quality
ground water quality in impact traffic
impact
parking studies and then they also list
and other special studies
and then it goes on to say or any other
study deemed necessary by the planning
board in order to make it an informed
decision
so um
my question is is i'd like to better
understand the purpose and in the intent
of this bill because you say list
studies so
to be
very specific
what is this bill asking to do are they
are they directing municipalities to
list within their ordinances
very clearly because i only spot checked
brookline i do not know if other
municipalities are in fact taking the
step to list studies and furthermore i i
do understand that again looking at my
municipality that they did list fees so
is the goal and the intent of this
legislation is it to clearly list
any such studies and also
to publish within the municipal
ordinances fees associated with with
those
could you clarify thank you
thank you for the question absolutely um
so it's good that that your town is uh
listing some of the things that they
would be
um studying however obviously the list
is
not
comprehensive
and
that
i believe you know
is uh
a problem
as far as you know
transparency and what the the cost of of
that application might be
um
and
there is
so
the cost of each study is going to
to um
vary
widely depending on how much
there is to study so you wouldn't be
able to say like oh we're going to
charge you a certain flat fee
for this study you would have to go
and acquire the study and depending on
how much work is it is
in that you know how much of the impact
it is
or how long the study needs to be
you know that's going to affect
obviously the cost of that study so i
don't think that it's even possible to
list
the amounts of what the studies would
cost
it's just a guideline to say okay we're
going to study the the parking and the
traffic
and
maybe the water table
you know these are the things that this
town is looking at when
when we set up an ordinance we set up
what is allowed to be
in you know each district let's say and
so if you have
industrial
things going in then you want to be able
to
make sure that the water table is going
to be safe and
and those types of things so those
things that you're looking at should
really be listed and not um you know
anything else that we imagined
you know or looked up on the internet
last week kind of a thing and we're
gonna
add that to the to the um person's
requirement for getting this uh passed
thank you follow up mr chair yes
thank you um and thank you for taking my
follow-up question so relative to the
language in this legislation
proposed section f
could you also
tell me if the the term substantially
impact is defined anywhere i'm
interested in knowing the criteria
for that because it says
after a study completion which would
substantially impact the issue
is that defined anywhere else in statute
that we could reference and could you
expound on that definition
thank you for the question
um
as i was saying before i don't
i'm not aware of anywhere that
substantially impact is defined and it's
not defined in this um
this ordinance if if you believe that
that is necessary and the that the board
would not be able to decide that on
their own
um whether
it had a substantial impact or not
um
with the um as already explained with
the
um caveat that if there was a
disagreement whether with um obviously
abutters
or the applicant
and whether it was substantially
uh
you know any decision made by the board
can be appealed to the zba by the
butters or the applicant and so
if there was a disagreement on that
issue that would be
able to be appealed and discussed
um more thoroughly with uh
you know the
appropriate through the appropriate
process
anybody else have any uh questions for
the representative
yes representative stavis thank you mr
chair and thank you for taking yet
another question
representative uh so
under letter f in your bill there are
several grammatical errors that i would
just like to point out
one is that you list studies
in line four
as a
plural noun representative could you
yes
thank you mr chair
do you mean that to be
a possessive
singular noun
it confuses me
thank you for the question let me just
just uh
re re-read
let's see
he's listening
yes you're you're right it should be
possessive thank you thank you and then
and my my my last question
uh
is about the phrase which would
substantially impact the issues studied
does that refer to the studies
or to the development
being reviewed it's not clear from the
wording of the bill
thank you for the question um
i'm not sure of the
a way in which
a study would impact the issue studied
so
i think that the only way to understand
that language is that it has to be the
plan it is the is the thing that changed
so any further questions for the
representative
uh
representative a question was brought up
about language would you expect that you
would
bring forth an amendment to correct that
are you okay the way it is
with the possessive
um
i'm happy to
draft an amendment i would be more
interested if the committee was um
wanted me to draft
an amendment to define substantially
that would be more of i'm happy to do
the possessive obviously that's just a
grammatical change but
um i'm happy i'm i'm willing to work on
you know whatever the committee
believes is is appropriate so
i'm happy to propose that amendment for
the studies
uh correction the grammatical correction
and um
if it is the will of the
the committee anyone could reach out to
me and say
and you know via email or say right now
that they that's what they would like to
see as an amendment and i would be happy
to do so um as far as defining
substantially any further
questions from the committee uh yes
representative
um if you're going to be doing an
amendment um
i'd appreciate it if um
you could include your testimony about
the definition of repetitive as meaning
referring to the same subject matter
in your
amendment too
that would be okay thank you thanks for
that
any further questions
uh any questions
from the public
we did have a request to speak from the
nhma on this
thank you mr chair nate grace for the
new hampshire municipal association we
object to this bill as written and based
on what i've heard here today we would
also object to the amendment
the first thing i want to point out is
that this would amend rsa 674 colon 44
roman 3 by inserting a new sub-paragraph
that statute is the statute that
requires a planning board to
adopt site plan review regulations and
lists
what is required in those site plan
review regulations
so essentially what this would do
is just require exactly what brookline
does although of course if there's
already a fee attached to it they would
already have to list what they what they
want so
it doesn't really change anything
um
and the problem is is you would you
would end up with a list exactly like
brooklines because
the planning board wouldn't necessarily
know all possible studies and
it might be the case for example that in
you know a place that's heavily impacted
by
pfas if
des
enacts a soil surface uh standard
that you know a project that would
that would result in
substantial
digging or something that would disturb
the soil might require some sort of
study related to that i don't know what
that is
i don't know if anybody knows what that
is at the point of at this point in time
but
a simple listing of all possible studies
doesn't really help applicants know what
they need because
you know certainly if you're proposing a
big box store you can assume a traffic
study makes sense but if you're building
a house that doesn't really make sense
um if you're building you know on top of
a mountain you're not going to need a
wetland study
but you are if you are in a place where
it's
there's going to be a possible wetland
so it doesn't really help applicants
narrow down what their costs are going
to be
already they have the option of going to
uh the planning board prior to
submitting an application
speaking with the board on a
semi-formal basis
saying here's kind of our plan what do
we need to know and there is an
obligation of the planning board to talk
to them and to say you know
based on where you are in town we've
seen that there are wetlands from other
applications you might need a wetland
study that's something you might want to
look into
and you know the list goes on from there
um and that's really the best way for
the applicant to know what the cost
would be before they go too far into the
project
and they can certainly do that at a
preliminary design phase where they
would go in
long before hiring architects or
anything and saying you know i i own 20
acres i want to subdivide that into 20
lots and build a residential
place what do i need to know and the
town is obligated to tell them what they
need to know about that
the other portion of the
bill as proposed
would prevent duplicate studies
already we have in place rsa 674 colon 4
hyphen b
and that's for the planning board and
rsa 676 colon 5 roman 5 a which is for
the zba
which
essentially says
on the one side the planning board can't
require substantially duplicative
studies those are the same studies as
the zoning board
and vice versa because if you have that
information once
you can't require applicants to go out
and get it again
um it sounds from the discussion like
there might be
cases out there where
an applicant goes out gets a study
and then the abutters who live next to
them
don't like the result or they don't like
what the applicant's doing so they get
their own study
both sides have the option of presenting
that to whichever board they're in front
of and that board has an obligation to
determine which one is best and it may
be the case the board needs to hire an
expert to help them sort through the
studies if it's a highly technical
analysis
and point out you know what the what the
errors are
um or what the
what the different factors are and then
uh it's ultimately the board's decision
as to what study is more persuasive
which one to believe much like a
courtroom
so that's
really what i want to point out to the
committee i'm happy to take questions
anybody have questions for the nhma mr
graves
yes representative manchapudi
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
from your testimony what i'm
understanding is that true that
this
bill does not clarify or
help
preventing repetitive studies
in all scenarios so when you change an
rsa it's not just one particular small
town but it also impacts
every municipality or city or every
community and how would this impact the
larger communities for example like in
nashua what would the zoning board have
to face if this
is it would it make it more restrictive
well thank you for the question um
so i
i really don't see how this would
enhance an applicant's ability to do
anything because they might for example
go in and say i want to subdivide my
property and build however many houses
they start doing a study and uh you know
they realize hey their wetlands here
maybe instead of going through the whole
process of getting the excavation permit
through des and all of that
we're just going to change the plan um
and then you have to make sure that
whatever information you've given to the
board corresponds with what your plan is
right otherwise why do it
so if their initial study didn't capture
enough information
to uh
inform the board about their new plan
then you have to redo part of the study
um and so
i don't think that this would
assist them in any material way
just a quick follow
mr chair yeah so basically it's not
helping
the person who's applying
to reduce the fee or do the repetitive
but it gives
the municipalities and the towns
the platform where as it stands now it
gives opportunity for all parties to
work it through if there is
uh any issues right right and under the
existing statutes you know you might
have
someone going with their application go
before the planning board the planning
award requires that wetlands study and
part of the planning board
approval process is that they
you know
they they can't improve the plan without
a variance so the affliction goes to zba
and halfway through that
process they realize
you know maybe it's more economical
maybe it's a better idea whatever the
case is they decide to change the plan
and if your initial study already
captured that the zba can't go back and
say we need to do the study again that's
already prevented under this under the
law and once they're sent back to the
planning board the planning board can't
say you have to go back and do the study
again because it's already
it they already have the information
that's not allowed
any other questions for the nhma
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
and that concludes our hearing on hb
1136.
our next bill to be heard is 1161
which is relative to ethics obligations
of
elected local and county officials
thank you
we have anyone that wishes to introduce
this bill 1161 yes please
please go ahead
no push the push button okay we're good
so thank you for hearing me i am uh
representative callum from sullivan
district six
um
and just for a little bit of background
i've been at this
and
so my experiences
are
the main reason for bringing this
and
i had input from others
in the county
so i think that this is a case of
the timing
is past due
um
you all have the paper in front of you i
don't know that i really need to read it
um
suffice to say that the attention here
the intention is to try to
bring the same level
of
ethics
to county and local government
that we ourselves as representatives
have to
assign to
and in the past there's not been
anything unless it's written entirely by
a local government
which they would still have to write it
but at least you would have
a
state statute
promoting that they do that
this bill is also co-sponsored
pardon me
by
representative stephen smith of sullivan
representative stapleton
of sullivan 5
and representative baxter of rockingham
20.
i don't believe any of those are here
today
so my intention was to introduce it
and
take any questions
thank you representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative so my
question focuses on line 21 of the bill
language
specifically the term
removal by the voters so i would like to
understand by what mechanisms
shall the person
be removed from by the voters
would it be
by
a recall election and who would initiate
that would it be the governing body
or
would it be by a petitioned warrant
article
potentially a regular meeting which is
probably unlikely
and most likely it would be by a special
meeting could you please explain
the mechanism by which this
person would be removed by the voters
thank you so um
that particular line
as it appears
was
put in by the writers from
downstairs
and
i'm not sure that i had
a grasp on legalities
to make that
uh
more specific
and
i struggle with that myself i
because i'm not a legal individual i
don't know
what
is the correct mechanism to make
something happen but i would
my guess would be that you would end up
with a special
election
or something of that sort
or if they mean by the people
that
for example the slackman
would have to pursue
pursue legal avenues which may be the
real possibility
i don't have a straight answer for that
follow-up mr chair
um
could you please edify me with regard to
special elections i meant recall
elections in new hampshire is is that in
our statute so um i asked that question
of
town council
and the answer i got was that new
hampshire does not have a provision
now
i did not look myself yet to see if this
is true but what i got in writing
was that new hampshire does not have a
provision for recall elections
as some states do
so
i'm confused about the mechanism myself
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
like you i've been a member of my select
board for many years and in my first
term or maybe my second term
uh myself and our two other select
people drafted wrote a an ethics policy
for the town a comprehensive one between
the three of us
we have two phds a masters and two
ivy league degrees
when that ethics violation or that
ethics policy was tested many years
later it hadn't been tested for a while
it was proven to be garbage
and it was proven to be garbage and
here's my question because you have a
right
to your first amendment to speak your
mind to say what you will say my
question to you is then
how do you reconcile your first
amendment rights against section 30 in
here which is your right you know you
have to adhere to ethics
that's the conflict i
i can't deny it
i
my issue was to try to get something
started
that
would take us to some point that people
who run for office would understand as
we as representatives do
that there are certain things you've got
to disclose even if you're uh if you're
a businessman uh a contractor you got
ten implements and three guys working
for you
and you bid on a job
well
if you're sitting on the board yourself
at least everybody in town ought to know
that you're bidding on something that
you're sitting on
that is my
main focus
and like i said i don't have all those
phds i'm just a joe blow who was in the
navy for a while and
i have all the best intentions but i
don't claim to be legal and know how to
do it
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
i
wonder if you have thought about how
this
proposed bill
would affect membership on boards the
planning board comes to mind
particularly
where often people serve on the board
because they know about something
it seems to me as though
this is going to create
a disincentive
for someone to serve on their planning
board because oh they developed a house
once therefore they have a conflict
could you talk about that a little bit
please so
so uh
if it were myself
uh and i were going to plan
sit on the board and i believe i had a
conflict
and in a couple of cases
i have mentioned those conflicts and
what i have done is said
i have a conflict with this interest
or this situation
and
so i will be abstaining would you like
me to leave the room
i don't think that that is anything to
expect a person to do the problem is
at this point it's really voluntary and
there's a whole lot of people who don't
necessarily
step up and volunteer that information
yes follow-up go ahead
my question was really more of a general
one
um the way i read the bill
uh
it sounds as though
uh shall have any interest financial or
otherwise direct or incorrect in any
business or transaction or incur any
obligation of any nature that is in
substantial conflict with the proper
discharge of his or her duties as
prescribed in the loss of the state
that seems fairly general such that
someone who works in the field might not
be able to serve at all i understand
your example of oh well i live next door
therefore
i'm you know i have a conflict or
i bid on this job therefore i have a
conflict but the first
the first uh
clause here
feels more general is was that your
intention
and you're saying starting right at
leighton five
uh yeah starting at line five
give me a moment please sure
uh
yeah it's it's very general
um
i think the problem here is
that
i don't think you can possibly write
anything that's specific to everything
that's why it has to be general
it's
lawyers
need to work on this and fix it better
than i've got it but
it's
i don't know how you would write
something that fits every single
situation
yes
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question i
have two questions
um
one is
has to do with line uh lines 21 and 22
of the bill
where it says that
anyone who is um
found to be in conflict with this ethics
policy shall be guilty of a misdemeanor
is it a class a or a class b misdemeanor
i don't actually know that uh penalties
are substantially different for each one
right and there is due process that must
be followed
that has nothing to do with removal by
voters
so how how would how would this bill
move someone
from an elected or appointed position
that is judged to be in conflict with
the guidelines of this bill that
outlines ethics
through the criminal justice system
to be indicted of a class a or a class b
misdemeanor how would that how would
that actually happen
who would bring the charge who would
hear the charge how would it happen
that's something i would have to
research and get back to you i don't
have an answer for that
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
um
many of the
boards
are either voluntary or it
pays a small token of
stipend
and if somebody
is
working full time and their expertise is
in that field that we want their input
on a board for example public health
board we want a doctor who is a public
health official
not in that town or you know
elsewhere but need to
sit on it
i
mean many of the boards in new hampshire
is voluntary so would this your bill
would it preclude
participation because of this high
penalty and high stakes
which is very vague
i
i think in looking at some of this
wording
you might
believe that to be true
as i said before my my intention
was more to get
uh people to
shall we say own up
and be clear
and recuse themselves
not necessarily to stop them from
bidding on a job
but to have them be clear so everybody
else knows
what's going on that it
doesn't as it might as it sometimes
happens
that uh
no one in town is clear about who's
actually
sitting where and doing the job
clay
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking my questions um
it does reference in governing bodies
and the definition of governing bodies
sounds more like it's an elected uh
position
for selectmen so on and so forth but um
where
i do agree that there could be conflict
i also sit on a board of aldermen um
and
anytime someone has a conflict for
instance um a spouse is uh
in the school
works in the schools and there's a
contract coming up they they always
recuse themselves um
if there's a
a they work for a non-profit and there's
some kind of grants that are going up
they'll recuse themselves from doing
that and so on so i i see it happening
within my within my town i think my
concern with this is that
um if we start forcing people to
disclose any potentials or possibilities
and it goes beyond
the governing body of the elected
officials we as i believe that
representative manju puti brought up so
my question to you is
do you feel that this could go beyond
the governing body the elected officials
do you think that just the voluntary i
know
pardon me here so i know that you
you put this through because p you felt
people aren't stepping up to the the
fact but is there a specific case i
guess there's a question that i'm asking
that that brought this to your attention
or any of the other authors
okay so um
in the past
in the town of unity
a selectmen
or two
a couple of different cases
in
in actual different
situations not the same
time you know
one of the individuals is deceased
uh
was sitting as a border slackman member
and
did things
that should not in my opinion have been
loud and there didn't seem to be any
teeth anywhere to make sure
that
at least
the individual owned up
also
elsewhere in the county
um
recently
an individual
um
who had influence on a board
don't know that he was actually a member
at the time
um
held property
i think the question was
are you aware of
other
situations
that
this
policy would be
so the answer would be yes sir
because i think i think if we bring up
individual cases we're going to cross
over the line of dupras okay
thank you
first we have representative gilman
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for uh my testimony my
question um my question might go a
little along your lines mr chair but
we'll see how it falls out
um
i sit on the executive committee of the
rockingham county
delegation
and my mother lives in the nursing home
so i have some control over the budget
that is spent
on her care is would you see that as a
conflict
i personally would not see that as
as a conflict it would
but
i don't know
thank you
how come you uh excluded uh appointed
people that appointed boards in my town
our zba is appointed by the moderator
so they would not have to follow this
rule
i think that was just something i didn't
think of
i uh i'm looking at elected officials
and putting them in the same
pot with the rest of us here
so if we have if we lost a member of our
board of selectmen
and the board of selectmen decided not
to
uh
do a special election
and appointed an individual with that
individual
follow under this guideline because they
was appointed
in my mind they would because it's the
job but
when i say appointed or
where i was drawing the line is people
who are volunteers let's say historic
society or something like that and
they take no compensation
purely
a voluntary situation
i would not see that
as a potential conflict anywhere
what i'm looking at is
elected officials or in your case what
you're what you're asking is an
appointed
official who takes who assumes
to me the point a person assumes a job
to fill a seat
for
a i don't know say deceased
elected official i think they're subject
to the same thing they accept it and
they're sworn in you know they're
they're taking that job so it's more
with the job than it is the individual
in my mind there is a big need for
this legislation
i'm not sure
it's uh
ready for
uh
to be
processed into law
we all live in small towns
and there's always a need for there's
always
the possibility
of conflict of interest to uh
to occur
i've experienced this
in our own uh small town
and i'm sure we all have
i'm looking at
where
it says disclosure required
on page one an elected member shall
abstain from participating in a vote
on any matter if he or she has a known
conflict
it's not just the vote
a person can
can
exert influence
by simply
participating in a conversation or the
discussion
so i think
that person who has a conflict
should not participate
should should
abstain from
participating in any manner because they
they could have a conflict the other
thing too
is and i'm i think one of my
my
colleagues had mentioned it
is that
a person could have a personal conflict
or
their brother-in-law could be involved
or you know you have to you have to take
families involved
so my my thought was
do you
for where it says disclosure
required would you agree with me
that we should
expand
the scope of that particular paragraph
to include
discussion
i would say yes to that
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
i'm curious about the education of this
this bill because
um for instance in my town of merrimack
and i'm sure there's many other towns
too we have an ethics committee and
they're elected
and
anyone can file an ethics complaint
about someone and they investigate it
and i i don't know what arrays of
remedies they have i don't even know if
any charges come to them
but how would that be reconciled with
your bill
like if would we have to disband our
ethics committee and it goes right
to the judicial system as a to be
charged as a misdemeanor
that would not be the intention i i
certainly would hope not
um
one of the one of the paragraphs in here
is that
it's to pro promote
uh local
and county municipalities to actually
write
stuff now
write your own
rules if you will
the town of unity doesn't have any
ethics rules and i've been sitting on
that board for like i said 15 or more
years
it's just not something we've done
however my two years in the county
commissioner's seat
tells me the same thing
so
the the the intention would not to be to
take away your rights the intention
would be to
promote
those
rights and we might even be looking at
your town and saying look what they're
doing maybe we should do something like
that
yeah thank you thank you mr chair yeah
that's what i was going to ask is is
there anything that prevents a town
from
implementing an ethics policy and
procedures
if this bill should not enter into law
i don't believe so okay thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative so
when i um
reviewed the language of this bill
in preparation for the hearing i went
back to rsa 21 colon 48
which
references the definition of a member of
a local or county governing body and it
specifically cites
members of select board members boards
of aldermen school boards and village
district district boards so my question
is that
in your prior response to a question you
had cited
that the
the purpose of this bill is um
pertain to elected officials so my
question is
did was it
was it an oversight to have
not included elected members to a budget
committee
that would be an oversight we don't do
it i mean unity
unity the selectmen
do everything right the budget there's
nobody else so i was looking at it from
our own perspective
yes representative clee
oh i'm sorry representative
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
so
um
i'm going back to that whole question of
what constitutes a conflict of interest
and i'm thinking about planning boards
both elected and appointed
all of those people live in town most of
them are probably landowners
so when they propose changes to the
zoning ordinance
they are affected by the changes that
they propose
does that put them in conflict with this
i suppose potentially it could
i would think that if there was
any situation like that the individual
would say
straight out i
have a conflict
but they all do
i mean think about it
if you live in town
and representative
sorry question please
if you live in town
you are affected are you not by the
zoning enacted by the planning board
so
you are
in conflict
because maybe that's advantageous for
you
i think that would
what i'm looking at is
the individual
who may
be
in a major situation of
personal gain
not
the individual
who owns a piece of property and
two doors down something's going to
happen
but it doesn't have
an opportunity for him to make money on
it i'm i i can't see how this
is intended to hit every single person
it's
intended
to keep
those who can
make
major capital gains or other interests
personal
you know and
keep them honest and have them step up
and say that they're
at risk
representatives davis
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um
my question has to do with your response
to the previous question
where
the bill states financial or otherwise
so
can you explain to me
what the otherwise might be
i suppose that that could be
a situation where
somebody actually receives
i know let's say there's a piece of
property and they can receive that piece
of property
but a
value has not stuck on it because
money didn't change hands only the
property did now we know there's a value
to the property
but i would think that and is included
in other gains
follow-up
thank you mr chair um
and so said person
who stood to gain in that otherwise way
shall be guilty
of a class a or b
misdemeanor
but when i read
the statute that defines class a or b
distance misdemeanor that kind of
activity is not punishable under new
hampshire law
by a class a or b dis mis misdemeanor so
i go back to my previous question
which is
has to do with the mechanics of
implementing this
bill should it become law
where it says this these individuals
shall be guilty of a misdemeanor
how does that happen
if it's not allowed under new hampshire
law
i don't have an answer for that i'm
sorry i'd have to research it
yes
representative you mr chair thank you um
representative
i'm here in this corner um for taking my
question
i'm just trying to wrap my head around
the intention would you believe that the
intention of this bill
is to enhance
individual
moral and ethical value system
by enforcing
a collective
moral and ethical system
i'd say yes
so
just a quick follow-up yes okay
so that's a very high stake in terms of
to doing it
enforcing it as a collective
value to
implement
individual changes
yes
right yeah thank you
uh
let me say that it's it's my sense
especially with working with the members
of the committee that they're all very
careful about
ethics
and want to see us behave in the highest
manner that we can across not just this
committee but across all
areas of government
so that's why i think you're getting a
lot of questions about some of this what
i'll call softness in the bill
let me ask you this
has this
narrative been reviewed by attorney
other than the ols team downstairs
oh
only the new hampshire municipal
association that i know of because i did
receive a call from them and i believe
he's here to witness okay
when you are
under this provision under this ethics
commit provision if if somebody has a
conflict
is it your intention that they disclose
that conflict when they recuse
themselves
yes
i mean when i say disclose not just to
disclose the head of contract but
disclose what the conflict is
i'm not sure that i'm asking that
in the
general term in the general terms one of
the reasons i think
you're getting so many questions is
for example if if
some committee members here sit on uh
local government municipal uh
boards uh
town councils or board of and so forth
and it comes to them a vote
on tax policy
where
as citizens of the community they're
certainly going to be impacted by the
results of that tax policy
would it be your intention that this
could be some conflict of interest
between
members serving in the community in a
position like that and
developing tax policy for the town
that's not the intention no
i
tax policy has to happen
so
it would not be the intention of trying
to hold everybody hostage to that
so so if
if citizen a
feels that that
they just went through a revaluation and
they think that their taxes are way too
high
uh if that motivates them
uh
to vote a certain way or to try to
convince other members to vote a certain
way would that be a conflict
i would think not
thank you uh
and given the uh the the
questions you've been receiving do you
would you recommend that this this bill
be passed before
perhaps criminal justice
committee to see if they have issues
with the bill because the fact that this
bill does call out
for
criminal uh
repercussions
yeah i would actually hope that it did
go before them
okay thank you i have no more questions
does the committee have any
further questions
okay
thank you representative that was a kind
of a grilling
appreciate you thank you through it uh
next uh kate horgan he wanted to speak
thank you mr chairman and members of the
municipal and county government
committee my name is kate horgan
i serve as the executive director for
the new hampshire association of
counties which is all of your elected
and appointed officials
to county government the association is
opposed to this bill
primarily for many of the reasons that
you have already raised particularly
around the shall be guilty of a
misdemeanor that was very concerning to
our membership but also all ten counties
already have ethics policies in place
that they feel are
aligned with best practices i would be
happy to provide a copy of those to the
committee if that is something the
committee would like to see um but you
did raise most of our concerns already
so i will wrap my testimony and i'm
happy to take any questions i would uh
recommend that you did
send those
policies that you have copies of
to
i'd be happy to collect those and get
those out thank you
mr chair i have a question
thank you mr t thank you for taking my
question so approximately
you know we have 280 plus
municipalities in the state
uh would you be able to give us like
more than 50 percent have their own
ethical ethics committee or
thank you for the question
representative i believe you want to ask
that of the municipal association not of
the county association
okay what kind of data could county
association give up i i can send you all
10 policies okay by the way we do have
the municipal association ready to speak
here
thank you
any other questions
for kate
seeing none thank you thank you
next
we have
natchez graves
do you want to speak to this bill
thank you mr chair nate grace for the
new hampshire municipal association
we
do not object to the concept of a ethics
bill
part of a large part of what we do
is
provide
assistance and training to
municipalities on good governance and
we help them work through ethical issues
as they as they pop up as part of our
legal services
side of things
so we're well aware that
there is quite a lot of
contention about this um
but i think as as illustrated by the
committee today this bill is probably
not ready for prime time
um there were a couple of things that i
wanted to point out that weren't uh
necessarily mentioned already
um lines nine through eleven
about the
disclosure of confidential information
that is probably already captured under
rsa 42 colon 1 hyphen a roman 2 which is
the oath of office statute that relates
to
disclosure of information that a
a member might learn in non-public
session
i would suggest the committee take a
look at that
if if they're going to consider this
bill and see how those two would
interact
in addition lines 15 through uh 18
about the ethics policy um
that would be developed at the local
level
um there already is a
statute rsa 31 colon 39 hyphen a
that allows a local legislative body to
adopt an ethics policy for
municipal wide and gives them
some pretty broad discretion about what
to do there that might be captured based
on what the sponsor said already under
that statute
um
as far as section one goes there which
are lines five through eight
um it appears that the sponsor may have
been intending to
to capture
uh kind of the the essence of a couple
of new hampshire supreme court cases
um we only have a couple on on ethical
issues at the municipal level
um and those are quinn versus concord uh
that's 108 nh 242
from 1967
where i guess the relevant line is
the court states we think misconduct in
office means simply the doing of
something which the officer ought not to
do or the failure to do something which
he ought to do in the conduct of his
office
each case must rest upon his own facts
and i think that illustrates
as has the committee's questions how
difficult it is to capture that today
and really that idea was repeated in the
case atherton versus concord 109 nh164
in 1968. i'm happy to take questions any
questions for nhma yes representative
max poody
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question my question to you which i
posed earlier would it be possible for
us to get how many municipalities have
their own ethics
rules
uh in new hampshire just
you know so that we have an idea i don't
have a comprehensive list it's not
something we collect data on
um i can tell you that it's something
that's very popular in our training
sessions so for example we do an annual
conference in november we have an ethics
section that i usually teach or have
been teaching for the past several years
and we usually get around
60 or so local officials who attend that
um just because it's so complicated and
there it it's really a case-by-case
basis
by the way those who registered for this
bill
there are six supporters and 29 in
opposition any other further questions
from hma yes
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
some boards uh in exeter almost all of
our it's all of our land use boards have
rules of procedure
which cover how a meeting is run and
part of it does
do with this fiduciary um
responsibility to declare the conflict
uh are those adequate uh i know that
there's one rsa that covers it for
cities and towns the one you cited
um
part of this bill
covers
uh counties and i haven't found yet a
similar thing for counties
um
well it ethics is such a broad area um
that it certainly plays into the the
rules procedure because those outline
the expectations of everyone involved so
when they come up they understand you
know what the application process is
going to be what the appeal process is
going to be how the board's going to
conduct itself you know there are other
parts involved too so
you know
one of the good examples that we've seen
court cases on is if you're a board
member but you're also in a butter to a
case in a land use
a land use case
and you for whatever reason sit as part
of the voting body
that
is not the right thing to do because the
court has an automatic presumption that
you have a conflict of interest there um
and so if that were appealed to the
court you'd see an automatic reversal um
based on the fact that's a
quasi-judicial body
and
and there's somebody on there who
shouldn't be on there
so that's one area where uh you know we
have clear law but
it does get complicated you know what if
your spouse is involved in something and
that's not something that's going to be
you know all that's not going to be
captured under your rules or procedure
uh i have a question for you um
well if you go to a paragraph roman
numeral
roman numeral number one
uh that whole paragraph
it seems to get it seems to be very
specific and then slides into the very
general as you get towards the end of
the pagra for example
my question is
if we're looking
to define ethics violations as any
financial
in any business
including any obligation
so that's very inclusive but then the
paragraph goes on to say that's in
substantial conflict
with uh official duties so who would
adjudicate the difference between
substantial and
non-substantial
i i think if this were
were to pass as written that that would
be something that would be have to be
decided at this new hampshire supreme
court
which is of course not something we
generally want in the legislative
context um simply because i don't know
what substantial conflict means and it
may be
the case that the supreme court says
that's going to be an individualized
basis um which is going to be
problematic thank you any last questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
our last speaker on this topic
uh linda
helped me with last
weinstein
yes thank you from newport
you support the bill
hi thank you chairman
i
had something prepared
and i think i'm going to go a little bit
differently based on listening to
everybody's questions on this
i have been an elected official in my
community of newport for over 10 years
and i've served on many different boards
and i'm a business owner as well for
many years
one of the things that i just like to
point out and i'm on a school board side
not a municipal side so you guys been
focusing on the municipal side here so
i'm going to reel you in and maybe try
to get you a little bit differently
sorry if i take this off sure
like you to see my face when i talk
one of the things that i'd like to bring
to point is
when we all go to
put our name in for a position
whether it be your position school board
position municipal position
most ethical people look to see what the
job entails
can i do it what's required what are
some of the processes involved
and we all have some
itching about ourselves why we want to
join this committee or board
that's why we're here to make a
difference
so when we go and we take our oath of
office after being elected in
we all do the same thing do solemnly
swear
and affirm that i will faithfully
impartially discharge and perform all
duties incumbent upon me to the best of
my abilities
to the normal person you would think
that makes real sense and implies ethics
as well
from there you go to an organizational
meeting where you select the chair vice
chair secretary and typically after an
organizational meeting where the
officers have been elected
you go and you review your code ethics
or your code of conduct in some places
and you all agree and sign it
there's processes involved with
policy
and you have policy committees i would
imagine it's similar across the board
if there is something that a board
member would disagree with in the code
of ethics they would bring it to policy
committee and bring it back to the board
with suggestions
my support for this bill comes
around the code asks not so much about
the conflict which you all have been
very focused on here
but the fact that the code of ethics is
a guide of principles designed to help
the board
conduct business business honestly and
with integrity
and some of those outline missions
values things like that it's it's common
sense things
so things like be prepared for all the
meetings read the material in advance
which you all have done here today
be respectful to one another and be able
to share opinions
be
informed about
the decisions you're making or if it's
educational understand what you're
talking about
those types of things
so my reason for supporting this is that
there is no teeth in ethics and and the
simplicity
of being able to
be sworn in under the oath office
or abiding by a code of ethics committee
or the board itself is run by
so for instance
an example
if you have a board member that has
maleficent intentions
that comes to a board with the sole
purpose
of being individual an i not a team
and refuses to sign a code of ethics
and
possibly just shows up
and roll call says i'm here and then
leaves
also get stipend public funds for that
position
they are voted in and
i know somebody over here represent over
here was talking about recall
there is no recall
for a board member
at school board member at least
so now you are stuck with a
[Music]
representative on a on a board that is
not participating
is trying to call cause chaos
and uh
is making the burden of the work upon
the other members not including
themselves
so when i think of code ethics it's kind
of a no-brainer
and i understand
all of your
concerns about conflict again you almost
think that that is
something an ethical person would say
especially
municipalities if they are talking about
a home that is
next to them i would imagine they would
have to disclose that you know i i'm
going to sustain because i
own the home next to me and i don't want
this board's decision to be reflective
upon my personal opinion
but when you have somebody that doesn't
want to abide by
an ethics that
an official official position is elected
to
that maintains a policy
i have a problem with that i would
imagine that
the teeth of the
fines
is questionable
how that works and
my two cents for that
i would am i allowed to give my two
cents about how it might be changed
um for me it would be as simple as
putting it in the oath of office
agreeable to rules and regulations of
this constitutional law
in the state of new hampshire and by the
board seated upon
and if they don't sign it
they are not sitting on that board and
giving them a time date to sign it
they have 30 days to agree
to it or not the problem is
and we all know this because you're all
here and this is why we're here
it's kind of the old
legal term if it's not in writing it
never happened
so if it's not part of a statute
somewhere
about uh code of ethics
people absolutely are going to use their
right to speech
which i don't think ethics has a
conflict to because it encourages people
to have the right to speak and listen to
people's differences
however
if somebody comes on just to create
conflict and chaos i have a problem with
that and for most people like you said
and the gentleman prior to me and
the woman i'm sorry forgot your name
most schools most municipalities
most legislative bodies have code of
ethics already
but there's nothing in
the rsa
that makes them abide by it and i think
that's the problem that i have so i like
that there's some teeth in it
so i changed my focus a little bit up
but hopefully
you better understand that
thank you are you willing to take some
questions
absolutely anybody have questions for
miss
wadenstein
yes uh representative gallagher um yeah
could you just spell your last name for
me please for my personal note-taking
purposes sure thank you representative
gallagher it's
e w-a-d-e-n s t e n
okay thank you i have a question uh if
what do you how do you decide or what
would you
decide would be the difference between
disclosing
an issue
versus recusing yourself on an issue
well i'm no legal
aid here so i can only give you my
opinion
i think that if you disclose or recuse
it's kind of almost the same thing
because if you're not going to
vote
it's a mute point but if you want to
expound upon it
[Music]
i think that
as
having sat on an elected official
position as long as i have in small
towns like we have in new hampshire
you can bet your bottom dollar that
there's somebody that's going to point
out why
you had to recuse yourself so it's
better just to say
why you're accusing for let me let me
rephrase my question
if somebody
has a problem with themselves and they
decide they're going to fix that problem
by disclosing the issue to the audience
and the board members that they're with
with the intention that they are going
to vote on it and
discuss the issue
as long as they disclose it versus i'm
not going to participate in the issue
i'm going to recuse myself in fact in
some cases they leave the
the uh deus and sit in the audience
do you have a problem with either one of
those
um
well
i do and i don't if that were in my
position on my board
and i've been chair for a long time
one of the things that
i welcome people to come on boards
with purpose
i would then say to that person
let's
put it to committee and do research
and then the committee can bring back
recommendations
that way it involves the
member that has an issue but it also
involves other people and it's a we
versus an eye coming forward with a
suggestion maybe i didn't hear you when
you started what board of commissioner
you are now
i am on the newport school board i've
been there a very long time
if uh if
someone came forth
and said to you
a fellow member of the board said
i have a conflict
do you require
them to
reveal to you what that the nature of
that conflict or is it just okay for you
to hear that they have a conflict and
that they've decided not to speak or
decided not to vote
well i think it comes down to a
personal's true north
because i wouldn't know that unless you
disclosed it to me
if you disclosed a conflict to me
i would
absolutely encourage you to abstain or
recuse for those reasons and ethically
for my own
true personal north i would have to
bring that forward and say
you know our board member so and so i
think needs to recuse themselves because
they've already disclosed a conflict to
me if you're if you're
looking to ask the community to vote on
the next
teacher contract
which i'm sure you've done quite often
and there's a member on the board who is
a has a relative who was a teacher
is is that considered a conflict of
interest
well i believe that there is already
some statute somewhere if i'm not
mistaken that talks about
small boards and small communities where
it is often that you will find a husband
or a cousin on a board
so
if
in particular this has come up with us
so i will give you that particular
um example
the person
if the person is on the board and they
are voting on a teacher con contract
they would recuse themselves from it
because of their marital status with
somebody yes are there any other
questions
seeing them thank you very much for your
testimony thank you very much for your
time
is there anybody else from the audience
that would like to testify on this issue
yeah
mr chair yes question for the chair
so can we
how many on blue sheet
four are against on this yeah i
mentioned that let me uh hit it again
just a blue sheet or online you're
aggregating everything this is the this
is the
the advocates for everything we don't
have the blue sheets anymore
we had six in support and 29 opposed
thank you
and this could change until the end at
midnight tonight thank you
okay next uh we're going to close the
hearing on
and
open the hearing on house bill 1179.
representative keller you're going to
introduce this bill again
are you going to again introduce a bill
thank you mr chair and
go right ahead thank you
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee um again for the record my
phone my my name is uh representative
josh okela from fremont danville and
brentwood
i
am introducing hb 1179 which is
relative to protest politicians
and uh
protest
petitions are
a form in which
some members of the community
may
uh be allowed to change
the
the threshold for
passage of zoning changes
from a simple majority
to a supermajority
and
some of the policies that
we as a state
are passing
are
and
and locally are trying to address the
housing shortages
and um
and affordable housing
and um just access to housing in general
and
what this this uh
this bill would do is if we are trying
as a as a town or as a community
to
allow for
you know to change our current policies
to allow for
um
more density or more affordable housing
or complying with new laws that that
require such
zones to exist
you know when we when we change the law
sometimes we need to change the the
local zoning ordinance to comply with
the new law
there is the potential that that um
someone might use this protest
petition to make it harder for us to
comply with the law or comp
make
our communities more
uh affordable
and so
this this uh
bill
is just trying to say hey if we're
trying to you know address the housing
crisis in new hampshire
and
we're trying to comply with a law that
is now
allowing you know
increased density of development or
reduced
dimensional
requirements of lots or
um that that
not be hampered by a super majority vote
requirement and that a simple majority
should be
allowed to
to pass those changes
and that's all that i have for this
yes
thank you chairman and thank you
representative yokola so i see what
you're trying to do here but uh let me
ask a question
about
the opposite side of this
suppose your town has adopted an
ordinance that allows for smaller lot
sizes
after it's been in place for five or six
years a group of citizens suddenly
discovers that it exists
files a petition warrant article
to eliminate
that dimensional standard
so
[Music]
and another group of citizens files a
protest petition to say okay if you're
going to change this you've got to get
two-thirds majority
so it seems to me that the whole protest
petition two-thirds majority simple
majority
can work in both directions so what do
you what's your response
uh
and i did not make that up by the way
thank you thank you for the question um
i'm
could i ask some for some clarification
on the question is
when you were describing the situation
you suggested that there was a
you know increased development allowed
in a certain section and someone did a
warrant article to remove that
um
maybe zoning ordinance or they're trying
to remove the um
the
any any uh dimensional requirements at
all for that area no they're trying to
increase they're trying to remove the
already passed zoning ordinance which
allows for smaller lot sizes so it's a
dimensional change so they're trying to
increase the size the requirement of
size development and there is um
and so currently under our statute you
would be able to have a protest petition
and
make that
that size increase
subject to a
two-thirds majority requirement and not
a simple majority requirement
and under this law this would not change
that however if they were to do the
reverse if the if the planning board or
a zoning board
or
if the planning board or a petition
uh
went
if this bill passed if they tried to put
in uh increased events density
development they would not be allowed to
do a protest petition for that is
is that kind of your question
follow-up yeah uh well then i think that
you need to clarify that this does not
apply to citizen petition articles
because as i read it now a petition
warrant article that changes dimensional
standards could not be protested
and i don't think that's your intent
are you saying that currently that that
um
that uh
citizen warrant articles are not allowed
to be protested
no currently citizen warrant articles
are allowed to be protested okay under
the way i read this
if it passed if a citizen petition
warrant article changed dimensional
standards it could not be protested
if it reduced the size
no
if
yes
okay
um
so
my understanding of the question is that
um
if i agree that
with this proposed change you wouldn't
be able to to um
protest any warrant
article
that was
citizen petition
and
for for changing dimensions of in any
direction and i don't believe that to be
the case because the the um the
the bill doesn't specify
what the amendment to the zoning
like the method of getting on to the
ballot
uh
is not specified in this this bill and
it specifically only addresses
uh reductions
of dementia requirements
or an and increase of density so
it would only be
applying to
ones that were trying to
let's say
remove the increased density development
it would not
this would not apply to
someone trying to implement uh increased
density
no but i'll take it up with
representative yokola later
sorry
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question so
i just want to to to be clear and
understand that what this bill is
proposing to do
so
i understand
lines three and four as written so just
to be clear
if there was a petitioned warrant
article
that
sought to the subject matter is to
increase dimensional requirements or
decrease
allowed density of development
so it's just the inverse that we're just
switching the adjectives here
so the subject matter still pertains to
dimensional requirements and density of
development but it's
what direction
are we going in so to be clear
the vote threshold to reduce dimensional
requirements
or decrease density that would still
require the two-thirds vote threshold is
that correct
so we're taking the subject matter
sorry
um thank you for the question
um
as i
as i stated before um the method of
getting the amendment on the ballot is
is not really relevant to the
to the um
this bill
um
however in in the
very last
statement that you said um
uh i thought that you were trying to
reverse
the the language in your question by
saying increase dimensional requirements
and decrease the allowed density but
then in your final
uh
reading of restatement of it you said
reduce
dimensional requirements and increase
or and
decrease the allowed density which
didn't make any sense to me so
i'm going to answer the question as if
it was completely reversed
and
i think that this bill if if you were to
increase dimensional requirements and
decrease
the
allowed density
that this bill has nothing to say about
that because it's only talking about
reducing
dimensional requirements and increasing
allowed density which
is the purpose of this bill and
so that we can address the housing
crisis if you're trying to increase it
um
increase the dimensional requirements i
think that you sh
that the current system is fine
would you like a follow-up
representative
no thank you
thank you mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question
um i'll put it
in a very simple term
you're trying to address
are you trying to address one specific
issue
with the sledgehammer
you're trying to nail one
nail
with the sledgehammer thank you for the
question no
are there any other questions for this
representative
i see no thank you very much thank you
um
is there anybody in the audience that
would like to testify in this
bill
okay thank you
mr
on the um
house remote testimony we have uh
zero support and one opposed
and that's house bill 1179
and blue sheet yes thank you
um
no one at all on the blue sheet
i'm going to close hearing on
hbo 1179
and open
the hearing on house bill 1183
and that is relative to the calculation
of property taxes for residents
i'm sorry
just give me one second
yes um that's a relative to calculation
of property taxes for residents 75 years
of age and older
is there anyone i want to introduce this
bill
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee um
my name is
representative dennis thompson i
represent coast county district one
the bill today is relative to the
calculation of property taxes for
residents 75 and older with respect to
their
school tax portion of their property tax
and what the bill proposes is to at age
is to reduce their
school portion of their property tax by
five percent per year for five years
for a total of 25 percent reduction
which would last for as long as the
person lives or their
spouse owns the property
the i was contacted by the municipal
association
a couple of days ago and asked
to
provide them with an amendment to
provide an amendment to clarify a couple
of items
number one would be on page one of the
amendment if you have it
lines six and seven
which would allow the town
to adopt or rescind
this discount
on the school taxes
online
it's
listed as 5
that's correct it was listed as 10
prior
um
and that also spells out the discount
over the years
to a total of 25
where that would continue on
the
last change was on the initial bill
it would would have taken effect in 2022
which
we all know can't happen
so we've changed that to 2024 to allow
the
tax collectors and
and the dra time to come up with the
forms and to process
any claims in the first year
um
if you have any other questions i would
be happy to answer them if i can
okay representative majori
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative taking my question i'm
curious why there is no means testing
for income
in this bill
well because
i thought about that a lot and uh and
i've seen some in the past that had and
there there are some other bills that
allow for uh
for elderly exemptions
um i think uh
one of them is a
veterans exemption
the reason i did that is my feeling is
that these people in particularly in my
district
we have a much older
group of folks
who have supported the public school
systems
their entire lives
and it seems like it's time to give them
a break
um we have many people up there that are
on the verge of losing their homes that
have they've lived in for
their entire lives
we have other people that live on a
thousand dollars a month social security
and the taxes continue to go up and
generally they go up
particularly in our area they go up
because of the schools
i know in my particular town we've not
had a tax increase
with the exception of the school
district
request in quite a number of years the
town has kept their budget flat
in order to try and assist the taxpayers
with this
so my feeling is
if someone
has more money they probably also have a
larger property in a larger house
and
this is restricted to two acres
the house and a garage
any additional land they own would not
be exempt
it needs to be their primary residence
they need to meet a occupancy
requirement for how long they've lived
in the town
and
with respect to a spouse
they'd have to be married for a minimum
of 10 years
[Music]
so
i didn't write that into the law for
that specific reason that we do have
some people
you know i mean it's
if they've had a uh half a million
dollar home all these years
they've paid substantially more taxes
than someone who has a hundred thousand
dollar home so i think they deserve
the same percentage of decrease
and it appears that the people eligible
for this
statewide would be just over nine
percent
so the impact um
the impact obviously
this was
i hadn't thought of it but it was
pointed out to me by
ms heck from the municipal association
that the
the impact of this is going to not be on
the schools it's not going to hurt the
schools at all
their budgets will
remain the same as they need
for the
following years but it will raise the
taxes on the taxpayer the the overall
taxpayer a little bit
and
represent representatives expanded
somebody got a phone or something on
i apologize mr chair i'm in the process
of putting that on mute sorry
go ahead
um
so that's that's the reason behind that
no problem okay representative stavis
thank you mr chair i have uh two things
one is a request to the chair
that we ask for a fiscal note
on this bill we have several
tax credit tax exemption bills that have
no fiscal notes
okay after um
after before we get when we get to
executive center section
we can take a vote and decide to send
that to
the finance
if you would like to do that thank you
mr chair thank you mr chair and and my
question thank you representative for
taking my question
as sometimes happens in life
um
older people marry
very much younger people
and they may stay married for a very
long time
and the younger person may have children
in school
so if i'm
75 years old
and i marry someone who is 50
and has children in school
and i pass away but i have
qualified for this credit
and my spouse qualifies
i'm not yet 75
i still have children in the school yet
i am still getting the credit
is that the way this would work
thank you for the question um
my
my uh
reaction to that i guess is that if the
spouse is not 75
um they would they'd be eligible for
that tax credit while they're married to
the person that is 75 or older if that
person should pass away then i would
think the spouse would have to reapply
for a tax credit if they're not 75 they
would not be eligible for it follow-up
mr chair
go ahead with follow-up
would you be amenable to
amending your bill so that it is
specified in the bill because i'm for
the current
yes
i would be ambiguous i would be amenable
thank you
our representative wrong
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um i'm curious on line
six
it says a town or city may adopt or
rescind the property tax credit
established under this section by the
procedure of rsa 782 colon 27a
um
so
it would either be by a vote of the i
haven't looked up that rsa but would it
be by a vote of the people or a vote by
the selectmen or the town council it
would be the taxing agency so the
selectmen of the city
um depending on where it is
[Music]
there is also a an appeal process
that's stated in statute that they can
appeal the
decision if they'd like to okay follow
up mr chair uh go with the follow-up
okay thank you and um
if this bill wasn't enacted so the the
tax savings that the the person 75 or
older would would um enjoy
that would be made up by other taxpayers
correct that is correct and would that
be a burden for them
i don't believe it would i mean it's
going to depend on the value of your
property
and
and the quantity of people that apply
for this credit and they do have to
apply for it it's not automatic
there will be a dra form that will be
generated
for them to apply for it and it'll be up
to the town
um either the tax collector or the
selectmen to decide whether it's
a legitimate request or not but
if you're 75 and you own the property
and meet the other criteria i
can't see how it wouldn't be a
legitimate request but they do have an
appeal process
as well if if they don't want to if the
select board or the tax collector
doesn't want to grant it for one reason
or another all right thank you
representative klee
uh thank you mr uh
chair
and thank you for taking my question um
i get this question all the time so i i
understand you know um the
i have nobody in the school i've been
living in the city for this many years
why can't i get a break
i will i will admit that the the lack of
um
means test does
um just kind of stick with me but
putting that aside what about someone
who's been living in the um
their municipality for 40 years namely
me not quite uh um
75 yet and um but
low income how do you how do you explain
that to them saying
versus someone who may have only lived
in the city
10 years but meets the 75 age
requirement has a 2 million dollar home
i'm gonna have to think about it for a
second but
my initial reaction is
that
we can't
draft bills for every eventuality
it's just not
possible and
i just think that if
there's a standard set down that you
need to live in the town for five years
minimum and you need to be over 75 years
old
i think there are going to be some
chances where low-income people
i don't know that they'll be hurt by it
but until they're 75 they're just not
eligible for it
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
um my question is
you know taxes
that help with the schools
it's a collective effort
if you want a good community to have
contributing
members in the community we have to
provide
educational system
so if you're making exception because we
are 75 i don't have kids in school
are we going to next make an exception
for families who are moving in
but don't have children why should i pay
for this
and i'm you know i don't have uh
you know i live by myself in a corner
and i don't need i don't use the roads
so i'm not going to pay for the roads so
are we going to make exceptions how are
we going to
[Music]
understand that under this statute
there'd be no
exceptions for
people under 75 years of age and
frankly my my reason for doing this is
many of these people if they've grown up
in the public school system and most of
them have
and have had children and probably
grandchildren at age 75 that have been
in the public school system
they want to support the schools but in
many cases they're just not able to do
it
um and make ends meet um
living on social security depending on
what your uh particular circumstance is
with social security you're not going to
get a lot of money to pay your taxes to
begin with and this seemed like a
reasonable way
that after people had paid all these
years
that they should get some sort of a tax
break we're not discounting their
property
or
the value of their land outside of the
two acres the house and in a possible
garage might sit on
so
they're still going to pay the full tax
on that including the school tax portion
it's just on their primary residence
thank you um
my what if you know in a transitional or
transient
population in terms of
you know i i lived in a different
community i paid the taxes my kids went
to the public schools and stuff then i
moved to a retirement
and i turn 75
and i come to new hampshire
now i can say oh i can get the discount
i haven't paid
into new hampshire but i came here
because it's attractive so are we going
to make
more
people come here because it's
we don't have sales tax we don't have
income tax we don't have property tax so
this is a
tax haven well
again you have to have lived in your
primary residence for a minimum of five
years before you'd be eligible to apply
for the tax
credit
um
beyond that i i have no idea
whether it would attract people to new
hampshire i would
pretty much say that most of the people
who retire try to
migrate south not not up here
particularly with the storm we have
coming
that's
really all i can say about that
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
uh
on line nine of the first page it says
that uh it must be owned and used as his
his or her
residential real estate
uh
on 915
it says if the real estate is owned by
the person's spouse
is this a uh an exception to the uh
requirement on line nine
first of all i'm gonna put my
are you talking about on the bill or on
the amendment on on the amendment i i
assume we're talking about the amendment
right
um
it would be
okay now i've read this could you repeat
the question all right on line nine it
states that the property is owned and
used by as his or her primary uh
residential real estate and then on line
15 it says if the real estate is owned
by the person's spouse
so you know it seems that there's either
a contradiction or an exception
well i think the way i i wrote that is
um
the
in one of the
uh previous representatives asked about
um the age of the spouse it's
it was intended to mean
that if they're married to someone
and the property is in their name those
two people live in the domicile but
they'd both be
if they're paying the taxes they'd both
be eligible as long as one of them is
alive
and over 75.
but if that
follow up please
but
like i said if you look at the the
requirement on line nine it says it has
to be owned and used
by the the it's their primary represent
uh
real estate
but if it's not owned
by the person that is qualifying
then
like i said is this an exception
or is it a contradiction
75 years of age who was liable for the
property taxes for the property owned or
used as his or her
residential estate or
residential
real estate
so it says that the 75 year old person
needs to be the person liable for the
taxes
if you have your
your father or your grandfather move in
to your home
if you're paying the taxes you're not
liable for the credit
for them
that
it doesn't answer your question but
um
ols wrote this
with
these other statutes in mind
so i would have to go back and ask them
thank you so uh
do you do you believe there's a a
contradiction
or is it or like i said isn't an
exception no
i don't i don't think it's clear
if the real estate is only the personal
spouse the couple
must have been married for at least 10
consecutive years
so
no i don't think it's a contradiction i
think if
it may very well be a contradiction
thank you if it's owned by the person
spells yeah i i'll
go back to ols
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking another
question that i am
i i am uh
trying to figure out if it's actually a
question but but this this
municipal county government has several
of these bills that are exemptions and
one of them is an elderly exemption and
i'm i'm not sure that there's going to
be a question in here so i'm trying to
figure it out do you think there should
be a reconciliation somehow
between these bills because we have
another elderly exemption which i am
going to be elderly according to that
one at 60 years old
but this one is 75 years old the other
one is a one-year residency requirement
this one is a five-year
residency requirement do you have any
idea i guess the question is do you have
any idea how we can reconcile
which one of these is the right one
and i that's why i'm not sure that i can
ask that question because
with all due respect there's no way you
could know the other bills that we have
in front of us right
i've not read the other bill but
um
i'm over 60
and i've never asked for tax credit
because of my age and don't expect that
i will
but i'm
probably better off than many of the
elderly people in our state
and
[Music]
i would
i would not like to see this bill
combined with that bill
um
i just think that 60 years old is way
too young to be asking for an elderly
exemption
although aarp gives out cards now when
you're 50. so
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i i'm going to go back to the means
testing and maybe i don't even have to
do that but if you have someone who owns
a 400 000 house 75 doesn't have their
kids in school anymore
and is not paying the school part of the
called tax bill
but you have someone who's living in a
40 000 manufactured housing unit
and has two kids in school
how does the where does the exemption
for the person with the larger property
end up it's going to end up in that
person with a smaller property is it not
i don't know the answer to the question
i wish i did
i
i think the way that i approached this
was
that if the value of your property was
higher you've obviously paid much more
in school taxes over the years if the
value of your property is
i don't want me to
sound contrite but minimal
then you've paid a lot less in taxes
and
yes
if this goes through and there are any
number of these people that apply for
this
there will be
there will be an additional
amount added to everyone's property
taxes in the town
and
it's
indeterminable what that will be because
we have no way to know how many people
are eligible in a particular town and
how many would even apply for it if they
were eligible
as you well know
we pass laws here
every year
that no one in in
the state ever hears about
or is
made aware of so um hopefully this won't
be one of those bills if it makes it
through but
i think it
we need to give these people an
opportunity to save some money
and this seemed like the best way to me
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking another question no problem
following up on what my colleague asked
about about other bills before this
committee that deal with tax credits or
tax exemptions
would you would you feel that it would
be right and proper
if if all of those if all of the elderly
tax exemption or tax credit bills passed
that they'd be cumulative
so for example if if if this bill would
pass
and somebody applied for this tax
exemption or tax credit
and received
20 25 percent off their property tax
bill but they also applied for and
received an additional exemption under
another law the path
should should those two be
added together to make an even larger
exemption how would how would the state
where would it end well i think that's
that's
where having the section in that allows
the tax collector or the selectmen to
determine whether
the
[Music]
tax credit is
able to be
applied for
i would i would think that most
towns or tax collectors would not
consider
more than one exemption they would go to
whatever the greatest exemption was for
that person if they applied for that
exemption
and give that give it to them if someone
applies for a veterans exemption because
that works better for them
and most of those people don't have to
be over 75
there they can be much younger and still
get the exemptions
on the laws that exist currently i don't
know about the bills before the
committee currently but uh
um
i think that the
uh the opportunity to decide that is
left with local government
and
you know probably a consultation between
the selectmen and the
tax collector
and if they're doing their job in my
opinion
they should
be
pointing people to whatever
the best deal for them is
tax-wise
and approving that
thank you and there is
always the right to appeal
thank you mr t thank you representative
for taking my second question
have you looked at
how
specifically because you're carving out
an exemption for school taxes for people
with 75 and older
how would it impact
communities where
two-thirds of the population is
elderly or
older
and
their school system still needs support
and we still need to attract younger
folks to live in that community
is this making that
accommodation for
the community to still function and
thrive or is it going to make it
constrict and kind of eliminate the
younger community
members coming in
i don't think it will one of the reasons
that i phase this in over five years i
get five percent the first year
um another five percent the second year
and down so that
the uh
the tax base has a
chance to adjust
to that tax credit whether there be a
lot of people in town or not a lot of
people
and
with um miss heck's permission
i will use your uh
example of a 400 000 home
um
did the math and came up with a
an example that uh she felt that
in an average town
if you had a 400 000 home which i guess
is average now
um
that over this period of time it would
cost you about 249 dollars additional
in property tax to make up for the
the uh
the credit
taken out of the school tax
so it doesn't if you're paying taxes on
a four hundred thousand dollar home at
twenty five dollars a thousand or
whatever the tax rate might be
two hundred and forty nine dollars a
pretty small price to pay the other
thing you have to understand is
most of us
have parents or grandparents
that at some time here in the future are
going to qualify for this
deduction
so i don't think it's we're not picking
on the younger people
we're just asking them to do something
they're probably already doing by
supporting
in some way their parents or their
grandparents and i'm not talking about
necessarily financially but
um
it's a
easy way to do it um
easiest way i could come up with to do
it
and i did look at the other bills that
allow
um elderly tax exemptions and some of
them are
convoluted i think
is the best word
and i think there are a lot of people
that just wouldn't understand them this
bill at least
you know a 75 year old person can read
it and understand it
and as far as attracting young younger
people my goal is to attract younger
people to the state particularly where i
live
we have a
currently have a factory that
needs 410 people and they can only
attract 160
because we don't have any young people
and when you look at the newspaper every
week
there are more and more people that are
being eliminated
just
by attrition
um i'm trying to keep the people there
that are there
you know all the towns in new hampshire
not just
in my district
thank you for taking uh
answer michael uh yeah thank you for
taking my question
uh
i'm gonna give you a scenario i'm 75 i'm
75 years old
and i have less than two acres
but
i have a commercial business on my
property or i got a home based business
how would i fit into this
or wouldn't i
well i would i would guess it would
depend on what your zoning is
um if you're zoning consider is it a
commercial property then it would not be
eligible for this this needs to be your
residential use
what if my property is mixed use
i i would guess that would be up to the
town to determine whether or not to
apply that credit to that
yes thank you representative for taking
yet another question from me
um what if i'm 75 years old and i've
lived in my home for five years
and i have children in the school
because my my children are not able to
care for their kids and so i am serving
as their parent
it's just another one of those
many scenarios out there that you can't
anticipate and i guess i would have to
leave that up to the
to the um
taxing authority
as to whether or not they would allow
the exemption my my gut reaction is that
i'm sure there are quite a number of
people in that position
currently
but
those children
we're not talking about eliminating the
school tax on any of these people at the
at the end at age 80 they're still going
to be paying 75
of the taxes that are
for the school portion of their tax bill
so that we're not
giving up that much what i'm trying to
do is give them a leg up on being able
to stay in their home until they're 80
and
be able to buy food and heating oil and
whatever
and granted not all elderly people are
in that position
but as i said before
um with the previous question
people that are
wealthier
are probably living in in much larger
homes
and own more property and they're paying
a much higher percentage of tax
than uh
than the people that i'm i've targeted
this bill too thank you you're welcome
for other questions
i have a question for you um
at the
end of the amendment it talks about the
appeals process
in case
someone's refused an exemption
yeah that's
for refusal to grant the exemption
i guess my question is
do you think it's reasonable that local
municipalities
are going to refuse exemptions once the
exemption's been determined
to be
in place by the state um
i'm sure it happens all the time
i i know of two particular instances in
my town where it's happened
um
and i feel i think the people dropped it
i don't think they appealed because i
did ask the tax collector about that
if they'd had any of those issues
and
i think that
if they qualify for the tax
under
the rsa
what reason would the town have for
turning them down
other than
as the representative had said they'd
applied for a different
tax in the past a different
decided that they couldn't afford
to give these tax exemptions out and
they made a decision that they weren't
gonna
we're going to allow any more exemptions
for the next
x period of time because
there was too much stress on their tax
rate
i think we'd be talking about a court
case
um because because there is an appeals
process and it does mention the superior
court in there i think that's where we'd
end up but you have to understand that
even though we're giving these people
this exemption off the school tax that
money is going to be made up by all the
rest of the taxpayers
to replace that budget for the school
and i think probably we'll find out that
again in
the figure nine percent comes
to mind
if there's only nine percent of the
taxpayers in the state that are eligible
for this and many of them
won't take it
i certainly would not
um
then i think we may be down to four or
five percent of people that would
actually take that and i think that
that the effect on the tax rate would be
very low very minimal any other further
questions for the representative
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony i thank you very much for your
time all of you and i'd like to invite
catherine hex to provide tesla
you katherine you've
mentioned that you have a comment but
you didn't you didn't mention whether or
not you had any preference for or
against the bill
hopefully my testimony will clarify that
sir so my name is catherine heck i'm
with the new hampshire municipal
association good morning mr chairman and
committee members
thank you for allowing me to speak today
um first i would like to say um nhma
opposed the original version of this
bill
um based on the fact that there was no
local option and we typically do not
support um extended
exemptions or new exemptions being
created as it does have a burden on the
municipal tax base however this is a
school specific issue so we took no
position on that outside it was outside
of local control
um the amendment has addressed the local
control issue
um so now we are neutral on the bill
because we have some clarifying
questions that i have discussed with the
representative who introduced the bill
i first wanted to say that based on some
discussion you've had i would like to
address that rsa
7227 which is the adopt and rescind
provision
allows the legislative body to adopt
this so that would go to a town meeting
vote which was
questioned earlier unless you are of
course the city council and then the
legislative body there's also the
ability to rescind it so exemptions
weren't being able to be met as to
another representative's question
because the town just couldn't take any
more exemptions then the legislative
body should most likely rescind
that they have this exemption in place
the second thing i would like to clarify
is that the example that
representative thompson gave for the 400
000 house and 249 dollars was based on
my community at the maximum exposure of
the 50 discount in the original bill
so that's how that math was done using
an 18
average population of people 75 or older
in new hampshire so those are based on
some average metrics i'm just doing some
quick math with my own tax rate because
clearly every homeowner will have a
different
effect based on their town's tax rate
and of course their homes value so i
wanted to clarify where that number came
from it's certainly not a statewide
number it's very specific
and that's my community and my school
district based on all of that
information and finally our clarifying
questions would be first does this
exemption is it in addition to the other
elderly exemption that currently exists
and the second one is the percentage
tends to cause a little bit of um
an issue when trying to set the tax rate
all other exemptions are based on a
dollar amount that the legislative body
adopts or the state mandates it's a
specified dollar amount so when the town
files its ms-1 form in september in
order to set the tax rate and the school
districts have to file their ms 24 and
25 to the dra all exemptions revenues
and credits have to be spelled out in
dollar amounts so that the tax rate can
be set
if it's a percentage we won't know what
that percentage could possibly be to set
the tax rate so that is another area
that we are concerned with because we're
not sure the legislation
addresses how the tax rate could be set
um
as the bill is currently written
and i will end my testimony and take any
questions that you might have at this
time any questions for catherine
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony oh i'm sorry uh representative
powell i didn't see you thank you mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
um
i'm just trying to formulate this
question here on the fly
so it's with reference to um you had
touched upon these cumulative tax
credits and exemptions so to be clear
is it true that
the qualifications are clearly specified
the criteria in statute and in fact it
not it would not be up to the
discretion of a tax collector or a town
official to grant that apart from the
clearly defined criteria in statute
correct the statute determines who is
eligible for an exemption
follow-up yes go ahead please
thank you mr chair so therefore unless a
particular tax credit or exemption
specifically says that
it's it's limiting and there's language
within it um
that these could in fact such tax
credits could and and our exemptions
could be cumulative cumulative
um that is my understanding and that
would have to be clarified
a question uh
with the this cumulative tax
i'll say refund or elimination
are you are you aware of any communities
that now have people in of this age
and tax situation where they pay no
taxes to the community
i am not aware of such a situation
is there any further questions yes
this is going to be a roundabout way to
answer your question would you believe
that nashua has over 300
taxpayers that are not paying any taxes
due to elderly tax exemptions
i would actually believe that thank you
okay
seeing no further uh
questions or comments
i'm going to close the hearing
on uh
hb
1183.
thank you
you're gonna i'm gonna have one more
hearing and then
we'll fade into lunch
but we're gonna
go on to hb 1184 which is the author is
authorizing the establishment of
revolving funds
representative lyon are you going to
introduce this bill i am the prime
sponsors over in judiciary and
apparently they're trying to exact like
40 bills or something so yes he asked me
to come over and introduce
okay thank you your floor is yours thank
you mr chair thank you members of the
committee um
the bill's pretty straightforward um and
i'll give you a it's a little broader
than actually we intended when we did
this film this bill came out of the idea
of if you have most of your towns you
know that a lot of police a lot of towns
have established revolving funds around
police details um where
um a fixed amount of money is put into a
to a to kick off the account and then
after that all the revenues received are
put into that account all the
expenditures are taken out of that
account and then any net profits for
lack of a better phrase are used to buy
police equipment
you know
vests and guns and ammunition and all
the tools they need
um we found out counties can't do that
um that apparently we're not actually
there's no legislative authority to
create a revolving fund you keep capital
funds but you can't create a revolving
fund like this
and so we wanted to do that because in
belknap county which i apologize the
craziness of belknap county again but um
again in belknap county we allot 20
thousand dollars to our sheriff's
department for the purposes of police
details and when he runs out of that
money he can no longer do police details
all of officers just don't apply and
work in other towns and road details and
all of that kind of thing because
there's no more money in the line item
for it
and so when we went to try to fix that
this is what we found was we needed to
create a revolving fund another county
creating a revolving fund to allow that
to happen the drafters at ols realized
that the language was also missing in
city funds and i think it's village
districts and so they tried to keep
everything uniform where towns it's
allowed it wasn't allowed in those other
areas so they wrote one bigger bill to
include so all political entities could
create revolving funds
so in short that's the bill
they use the same exact language that's
in the town
statutes i think it's a 35 chapter
to create the county
village district and city language as
well
the way the fund works if you have if
you're not familiar with the towns is
that it would be a vote of the governing
body to establish the fund in that vote
and in that motion would have to be the
purpose of the fund and also the
expending authority for that fund so
most cases in towns it's the selectmen
in this case it leaves it to be it could
be the delegation but it also more than
likely will be the county commissioners
in this case will be uh what the motion
would look like so
i'm happy to answer any questions
but again that's kind of the basic of
the bill it's more of a housekeeping
cleanup bill to put all those political
subdivisions on equal footing and again
to take care of this particular need
that we found out in counties that we
can create a revolving fund for police
details and let them basically be
self-funding for their some of their
equipment
is is it your experience that
these police details
pay for themselves
in terms of the amount of money
collected from
from the
most often construction site or the
whatever the details for
thank you for the question mr chair so
yes it's my my understanding is i'm i'm
a retired i'm not retired i'm a former
police officer spent over a decade on
the job i took all my money out into
computers and made a lot more money but
when i was a police officer these these
uh the fees that they're charged are
always looked at to make sure that
they're not costing the municipalities
money but they're either breaking even
or making a slight profit
and so in the case of sanderton my town
where i'm the town moderator um ours has
been we've been able to pay for police
improvement so again replacing
bulletproof vests replacing safety
equipment and cruisers and those kind of
things
and we've been able to use what little
bit of overage that shows up in these
funds to be able to pay for that and not
affect the taxpayer directly any other
questions for representative lang yes
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative lang for taking my
question
what's the difference between a
revolving fund and a capital reserve
fund
so the my understanding when i read the
chapter was that a capital reserve fund
is usually used for building and
facilities whereas a revolving fund is
can be used for other purposes okay
follow-up
um where i'm from merrimack um our town
operates most of our budget is like 22
capital reserve funds
and um we like that because it keeps our
tax rate stable but every year when we
go to um when we have town meeting we
have to approve any money going into it
and would that be the same be true with
the revolving funds it would not because
we're not actually so in the difference
between capital reserve funds most time
using taxpayer dollars to fund it either
through an unexpended fund balance is
usually where it comes from
whereas this is not using taxpayer
dollars so once the funds established
the money coming in would come from the
details the money going out would be
going to the police officers and so
there's no tax dollar expenditure oh
okay so revolving funds are only funded
through
um non-tax revenue correct okay thank
you representatives davis
can you give me some sense of what that
non-tax revenue might be
so again i i looking at belknap county
and again that's the representative i
have is is
the reference i have um belknap county
we we put twenty thousand dollars into
our we annually budget twenty thousand
dollars which does come from tax dollars
uh into the police reserve fund and we i
think the number last time we got back
was a little over forty thousand dollars
through the various because it also
depends on the detail so some are paid
more than other details so it's it's
it's not a flat number we can is
representative
is it true that what you're talking
about i see some confused faces
difference between
revenues and expenditures
so right so the difference is again so
on the on the revenue side is what we
take in so i'll use again belknap county
we have bank of new hampshire pavilion
which hires a lot of police officers
during the summer for their concerts to
be able to maintain security that's an
outside considered an outside detail and
the various the town of guilford manages
it and they they put money in but
again the way it weirdly works is that
in this case is that the town of
guilford manages it
we pay the bank of new hampshire pays
the town of guilford who then pays the
police officers
but the the county pays the police
officers too so for their hourly rate so
to speak they pay first and then later
on collect the money so it gets kind of
messy and the idea is with this reserve
fund it would with this re revolving
fund that would not be the case
any other questions yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
um
once established
this
continues in perpetuity is that your
expectation or are you hamstringing the
future
boards are
so again so
once the fund is established the idea
will be self-sustaining right so the
money that comes in from the revenues
from the special detail will be higher
than the revenue the expenses going out
to pay the police officers are working
that details so again the idea is it's a
self-sustaining fund it'll keep the
money coming in we'll pay for the future
there'll be a one-time expenditure for
the county to be able to start the fund
off and then once that's done there'll
be no more expenditures from county no
more tax dollars going into it
um i'm looking at page 2
line 22
facilitating transaction relative to
group net metering and before that
energy conservation so all these
different line items
are you going to be establishing um is
the intent to have different evolving
fund for all these
thank you for the question again this
was taken from what's allowed by town so
they cut and pasted everything that was
in towns into all the other political
subdivisions so there's uh it was all
equal so again
um if you were to establish a fund you
have to specify the purpose and that's
in there so again if you wanted to do
one for facilitating transactions
relative to group net metering
that would be allowed but you would set
up a fund specifically for that with its
dedicated purpose and its dedicated
dedicated persons who are allowed to
expend from that fund
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so i want to be
assured
that with regard to these revolving
funds no monies shall be raised nor and
appropriated by or through taxation so
i'm looking at page 2 and line 25 where
the language references
and any other revenues approved by the
legislative body now i understand that
that's not taxation that's not monies
being raised and appropriated through
taxes but could you just clarify
some examples of
what
revenues approved by the legislative
body might be
no i actually don't think and i think
that was a catch-all because um to the
other other member before we're speaking
about
sometimes we don't know all what's going
to come up in the future the intention
of the bill is that again because you're
specifying when you create a fund you
have to specify its purpose and you
would also specify what the funding
sources are that when you create the
fund and so i think this is uh
uh uh i guess if i if i were to look at
this and i would use uh representative
manjapudi's
statement about net metering so you may
set up some sort of fund where the
revenues coming in from that metering
might go into a fund that would
future
fund other net metering projects within
the county or town or city so rather
than having so that it's a
self-sustaining fund that allows growth
within the community in a in a green
energy environment that could be the
purpose again it's up to the legislative
body to decide that but i think that's
the intent of that is to identify what
that if there's a revenue source that's
directly related to the purpose of the
fund that revenue source could be used
for that fund
any other questions yes
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um this may be
covered in here but
on the wild
aspect that a county might have some
extra money in a revolving fund could
they
donate that to a town's revolving fund
for the same purpose of
like an ambulance service from the
county and the town
so again i i i didn't hear all of your
question you're a little too far from
the mic so i couldn't hear you but if i
understood your question about ambulance
funds or donating money so again you
could uh create a fund that would allow
for donations again if that was one of
your someone wanted some citizen one to
donate money towards an ambulance again
my town also has an ambulance fund we
use the ambulance billing process to
keep that fund so we can pay for our
next ambulance when we need it um so you
could in theory do that also
i don't know that many counties that
have ambulances or fired trucks but
any further questions oh representative
tripp
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my it was actually
it's not a question it's a uh
there appears to be some clericals in
the bill
uh if we go to page two
line 27
it says shall not be considered part of
the county's general surplus
should that be uh
city
yes again i think this was a cut and
paste that though
i'm just pointing out there's some
clericals correct uh if you go to page
three
line 24 it says uh the county general
funds again right so it should be
village districts so
like i said there's some clericals yeah
i think there was just an error by the
ols and correcting it so it would need
an amendment to clear that i'll be
honest with you it wasn't our intention
to scoop in all these other ones and i'd
be completely okay with you removing the
city villages and everything else and
just make it about the county because
that was the intention of this whole
conversation
any other questions
thank you mr chairman thank you
committee members for taking my
testimony
and we have
some additional testimony on this bill
from
nhma
catherine
good morning once again for the record
my name is catherine heck from the new
hampshire municipal association and
thank you for allowing me to speak mr
chairman and committee members
we take no position on this bill as i
did speak to the sponsor and the goal of
this bill the intent was to allow
counties to have the same powers as town
cities and village districts we did want
to point out um and i did speak to the
representative who sponsored the bill
that
currently cities under
441 do have the powers to open and run
and establish
these revolving funds because they have
the same powers
as a town and under rsa 52 1 village
districts are allowed to
use any provision a town has once
they're created to further the purpose
for which they're created
so
if they can if they're running a fire
safety program they can have it for the
fire services for example because it's a
specific reason so the law already
allows for that and we are concerned
that this actually doesn't clarify
it
makes it less clear what the law would
be because village districts could
interpret that they could expand
their ability to open revolving funds
for purposes for which they were not
necessarily created
so towns under rsa 3195-h that is the
template in standard language that
you're seeing throughout
this bill
we have asked that the
counties review this or we request that
the committees because counties do not
necessarily perform some of these
functions
so i'm not sure that the legislation and
again we don't represent the counties
but would need to address
items that counties do not currently
perform
or have the capacity or the legal
authority to perform
and finally
for consistency's sake
if the committee wishes to leave the
language as it is written for
cities and village districts
they're giving the
commissions
the
ability to
be the custodians of the fund and
typically that's a treasurer's role to
be the custodian not the governing body
but a treasurer that needs to be
separated to be consistent throughout
the law
and finally there was a question asked
by a representative about
fees and charges and other income
the purpose of these
types of revolving funds is to have a
revolving source for self-funding
programs or
to offset costs through self-funding as
much of a program outside of taxation as
possible so the legislative body when
they create these funds allows for
fees charges and any other income it
sees fit during the creation of the fund
to go in and recreation is one of the
easier examples because if you have a
baseball program and you charge 35
so that's children can participate
it's so it can continue to grow that
program and you're not raising and
appropriating those dollars in the
future
any surpluses in those funds can
certainly be used only for the purpose
for which the fund was created so they
cannot be transferred to for other
purposes if that makes sense so
recreation cannot buy a fire truck
if that makes sense so any surpluses
that grow are to sustain the programs
for which they were created and that is
the design of the funds and i believe
that's the intent of the sponsors to
allow the county to have the same
authority to do so
any questions for nhma yes
representative tripp
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh
if uh a revolving fund is created for a
purpose and that purpose goes away what
happens to those funds
so that has to be a vote at the town
meeting
or by the legislative body to
close the fund and repurpose those
dollars and it should be still
relatively within the intent for which
it was created but that's a specific
warrant article or vote by a legislative
body sir thank you
yes mr representative
um thank you mr chu thank you for taking
my question so if a revolving fund is
established
and could it be invested
to
you know separately to
make it a more sustainable fund
or does it uh come under
other regulations that you know it's uh
you mean an out you mean an additional
investments um like to gain interest
yes it can be in an interest for example
it can be in an interest bearing account
however it has to use all the prudent
investor rules it certainly should never
lose any principle i mean there's all
sorts of rules that go around that but
yes it can be in an interest-bearing
account
okay thank you you're welcome
yes representative power thank you mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so based on your analysis of
the bill as written is it your opinion
that perhaps to address the points that
you um addressed in your testimony that
there should be it would
behoove
the um
this committee to to look for an
amendment to address those points
um yes
we would
like the sponsor
who has agreed to consider proposing an
amendment that would strike the village
district and cities out of it and i have
requested that again they have a
conversation with the counties to make
sure all the language is consistent with
county authority and the purpose for for
which counties can operate so that the
law is consistent throughout thank you
for your question any further questions
for nhma
seeing none any any questions from the
audience or
those that might be uh interested
the only thing i'll say is i'll be happy
to work that amendment so again
committee doesn't have extra work if
you'd like me to i'll get it drafted and
bring it to the committee
thank you
thank you very much thank you
okay uh
hearing no further testimony
on hb 1184 i'm going to close the
hearing
and we are going to take a lunch break
and i would ask
everyone to be back in their seats by
uh one
1 30. how's that 1 30. eat fast we'll
get out here a little earlier
i'm sorry 12 30.
quick catch
all right see you in 12th at 12 30.
representative majori
my friend from litchfield how can i help
you
i i took offense to your
your reference to uh
people who have high degrees
i
i don't think that should be held
against anyone
you know i will say
you
welcome back
in session
we're going to hear
from representative gallagher who's
going to introduce hb 1219
hi thank you
so i'm here to
i'm eric gallagher
from merrimack county district 15.
that's concord ward 6
and i'm here to introduce hb 1219
relative to parking requirements for
religious institution affiliated housing
development projects
and
um i seem to remember
um previously there being something
about like
if
you're on the committee you can only
introduce but you can't also testify to
it or something or
what's the procedure again the way the
rule goes you can introduce it and you
can speak to the bill
but um
you can't
once you're done speaking to the bill
you can't continue to advocate for the
bill
either from where you are or you if you
come back to your seat
you can you can
vote on it when it comes time to vote
uh
probably the
next session but
yeah you can't advocate for the bill
that's your bill
um
okay so that that's after i go back to
my seat so i can speak to it now then
right all right so um
so
this bill um is basically
to prevent
requests
for
churches who
build housing from being
denied on the basis of
parking
so it's based off of
ab
1851 from
the
from 2020 in california
um
i i heard about their legislation
and thought hey this could actually help
um
solve some problems that
we're having here in new hampshire with
housing um so you've heard
you've probably all heard of um
the term nimby for not my backyard and
um some of you have probably also heard
of the term embi for yes in my backyard
the phrase associated with this is
jagby
yes in god's backyard which i want to
make that the title of the bill but oh
else won't let me
um
so basically one thing
that um
urban development
advocates
um
dislike is
when there's a church with a really
large parking lot
and
it only gets used for
um
it only gets used like say once a week
if the church only has services once a
week and some churches have agreed yeah
we should
we we might want to turn our parking lot
into housing
so they go and try to turn their parking
lot into housing
but
then
they get stagnated by local zoning rules
so if you look out the
if you look out the window there
you can see
the sacred heart church
and
on pleasant street
that
used to be a church it was able to get
turned into housing
because
the church had completely shut down
and just wasn't even being used as a
church at all it was sold to
um
it was sold to someone else
and then redeveloped so um
none of the usual
religious zoning
requirements applied anymore however
there's some other
some other churches exist
where
the church hasn't closed entirely
it's just got a declining
congregation
and um
they want to continue using
their church
as a church
while
also
maybe turning their parking lot into
housing or some of the rooms within the
church into housing
um
so um
not quite sure if this is a conflict of
interest or not but my own my own church
uh wesley united methodist church um
runs this program called family
promise where um
we house homeless people temporarily
and want to set up
the offices for this program within our
church
i i don't know if that would apply
specifically to
this case since its offices rather than
actual housing itself but
just an idea of where i'm coming from
so
i see this as both a housing issue and a
religious freedom issue
um
you know many
many religions and dominations see it as
part of their calling
to
help our
unhoused neighbors
and i believe that we should be making
it easier for them to do so
rather than putting
um
putting additional
requirements
on them
so as for
um as for the specific language
in the bill um
yeah that's all
basically i just asked ols to
adapt
ab-1851
for me for
the purposes of new hampshire law
so
the requirements it prevents
planning boards from
requiring that's where they got um
all that language from
so
um i'm aware um
there may be some objections about
local control um
about since
it prevents planning boards from being
allowed to
prevent
it prevents playing boards
from being allowed to make requirements
for things
but um i see it as
um
just a
make making
an attempt to make local control
even more local moving it from the
municipal level to
the congregation level um
so
and also
so why focus on
parking requirements specifically
as opposed to other zoning requirements
that might come into play for housing
like this well
so par
parking
one thing about
parking is it contributes to
the
pervasive car culture that
our state has i i don't have a car
myself and
it's often
just the general assumption that
everyone has a car
and
that um
and everyone should have a car that
gets reinforced by having parking
requirements for things
um
and it
doesn't and
it doesn't really
do much for
those of us who are either
too poor to afford a car or object to
car ownership based on moral or
religious grounds
so i think
it would be better to use
parking spaces for housing people
instead
so that's
why i propose this legislation and
i'll take any questions
any questions from the committee yes
representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative gallagher for taking my
question i have two questions one is are
you
um
would this be transitional housing you
talked about people without homes and
you know
or would it be like a
residential co-op where
it's
people who cannot afford on their own
to own
a home or small and live
and walkable community kind of thing so
from
those two which kind of housing are you
looking at
um i mean i think either would be fine
the legislation
the legislation doesn't specify one or
the other
it just says um
a developer
developers it applies to housing
development projects affiliated with a
religious institution
so i think if
a religious institution wants to do
either of those ones that it could apply
a follow-up minister yes
thank you um
you know a few years ago over a decade
ago
nashua i was part of the national
interfaith council
and we had religious
organizations churches and
temples
hosting a whole
group of
people with no homes
and transitional and they were housed
temporarily i mean they could sleep but
you know they had to rotate and finally
the group
managed to get a
school that had
convent that had uh open space or the
large space which made it a long
long-term transitional uh housing which
was called the rosemary um
house
which gave extended period not like the
short-term
transitional that helped significant
number of families
that had children
that could stay in a home
and could save
get a job
and move out in two years
to have their own place so that kind of
gave a good base
in um you know nashua and area around
so
that you know from that thought process
i'm asking if it could be you know at
that time because we didn't need the
new building it was in the basement of
the
churches but if this is in building
something in a parking lot that would be
a more permanent that could
help
transition so
with that
yeah i think that's a good example of
a
situation that this legislation could
help with
any other comments or questions yes
representative
trump you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
uh
i notice in your uh bill that you use
the phrase religious use
uh parking spaces is is that a uh number
um
well
the it says the number of religious use
parking spaces so since
i mean it's not
it's not saying
um
it's not setting like a statewide number
that
um religious used parking spaces always
have to be it's just
restricting what
criteria
local planning boards can set for
that number
i noticed uh
on the uh
there's also a uh uh
on line twenty it says planning board
may require one parking space per unit
uh
is is that a minimum or a maximum
i think
i think it's
an exact
um
sn may require exactly one
i i
i think that's um
just to
handle the case of
handle the case of the legislation
potentially
preventing
preventing planning boards from setting
any parking requirements whatsoever
i think instead it's just saying okay
you you can set
you you can't set a requirement but
it can just be this rather than
your current full range of requirements
that can be set
thank you
yes
representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative gallagher for taking my
question it's kind of an ill-formed
question but i'll give it a try
do you anticipate or do you know of any
religious organizations that have
created
these kinds of housing
developments
and have those religious organizations
had to set up a separate
corporate entity to do so in other words
could they no longer enjoy their
tax-exempt status
if they became landlords or developers
and and my and my
follow-up question is
can you anticipate any
um
any objections by
commercial developers who might claim
that religious institutions were giving
uh were being given an unfair advantage
and a preference that they do not enjoy
um
so
um well as for the first question
um
well this
this uh the california legislation that
this is based on has only been law for
um
for
like a year
and a few months at this point so i'm
not quite
sure what exactly the structuring
the
structuring of
organizations to build this housing
under the terms of legislation there are
using
and
um
as for the second one um
i mean
as to whether
it's
um
whether it's privileging
religious institutions over commercial
ones i mean
i think so does our constitution it
provides the freedom of religion but it
doesn't provide for a freedom of
commerce
so um i think
i think it's okay to be um
i think it's okay to be preferencing
religious institutions over commission
commercial ones and
that's um
that context
yes
representative um
gilman
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative gallagher for taking my
question
uh
i am uh
guessing at what
religious use parking spaces actually is
defined as but i really think the
religious institution affiliated housing
has some
uh opening spaces do you consider that
housing
uh for people who attend the church
on which
the property the church is on
um could you rephrase the question
um i i just want to know if you're in
your
definition of religious institution
affiliated housing
if one of the requirements of being
uh renting one of those units is that
they are a member of that house of
worship
um i i don't think i don't think they
have to
so
um
yeah there's a breakdown between
religious used parking spaces um
and then other
parking spaces so this is about
replacing
the religious use parking spaces with
the other type of parking spaces
so um
my assumption would be that
um if
the if the um
religious
used parking spaces
can't currently be used
as parking for housing
then
that
this legislation would mean that would
remove that requirement and
mean that they can be used for housing
regardless of
whether or not the person in that
housing is a member of the
institution or not
it would just be general purpose
parking rather than specifically
religious use
i do um
have you considered the
tax implications of this
um because if the housing is on
uh non-profit
church property
then we're not paying any
taxes for the
living
housing
or do they have to divide the lot so
that there is the nonprofit church and
then the for-profit
so this is this legislation is just
about
the um
reasons why a planning board can
deny permits for a housing project
if a planning board wants to deny
a permit for one of these projects based
on
tax grounds they can still do that
because that's not about parking
requirements
it's just saying that
it can't be
it can't be solely due to parking it's
the
only thing it's saying here
uh representative matthew pony
thank you mr chair thank you
representative gallagher for taking
another question um i'm just trying to
clarify
parking lots are parking spaces
for a religious um entity is based on
the number of
uh members in the congregation or
attendance
on an average correct
uh
i believe so that sounds correct or the
capacity of the building that can hold
200 whatever and then you have to
offer so
this legislation is only
addressing to use the parking lot so
don't deny
construction based i mean construction
of housing on the parking lot based on
the membership congregation and you also
alluded to the fact that dwindling
congregation members so the church might
have a capacity of 250 but currently
only has 100 members
yeah
is that your intention
um yeah i believe that this
um addresses that
okay thank you
yes uh representative thank you mr chair
thank you representative for taking my
question does this bill or do you
contemplate with this bill that we were
only talking about one
lot or are you talking about all of the
property
that is owned contiguous or not
by the religious institution
thank you
um
so to be honest i'm not really too
familiar with how the development
process works my assumption would that
would be that um
it would be that it would just be done
one yet at a time but
i i i guess there could be potential for
multi-unit projects
in here as well um i'm i'm not sure if
you'd like
if you'd like
there to be language
clarifying that i'd be open to that
yes
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative gallagher for taking my
question are you aware of any religious
institutions in new hampshire that are
currently exploring
having housing on their property
and if so if if this has been an
impediment to them
moving forward on that housing project
um
well
i mean my own but
um i i don't really
know much um
but yeah i
i haven't really
consulted much with
people from other congregations though
any other questions for representative
gallagher
thank you
and and now we have uh some commentary
from the nhma
mr graves
and nash feel feel free
to wipe the mic with the clorox if you
want
nate gray is for the new hampshire
municipal association we object to this
bill
there are a couple items that i would
like to point out
our main objection is this is a
statewide zoning mandate which we oppose
generally
we prefer that
and current law provides that most local
land use decisions are made at the local
level
and that's what we advocate for
um there are a couple technical
questions i have about the bill and i
don't have answers to them
as representative tripp pointed out
earlier
there's no definition of religious use
parking spaces and i'd also note that
there's no definition of religious
institution affiliated housing
development project
um and that that leaves it a bit vague
about how this would apply and
specifically um
how this would would act as a law i
understand the sponsor's intent is to
allow
religious organizations with large
parking lots um that are seen declining
membership to convert a portion of those
parking lots to housing
but i don't think that's necessarily
captured by the language of this bill
i would also echo
or i guess answering the affirmative
representative manure's question that
the
language here used is vague um so it's
not clear that we're specifically
talking about parking lots in all cases
it could be the case that
a religious
institution whatever that means decides
to develop some housing
on another portion of their property and
that
under this uh provision appears to
relate to how many parking spaces they
they need and it's just not clear how
that's going to interact
and the last thing i want to point out
um is that
over in the judiciary committee i just
learned as this committee was
meeting earlier today
there was a bipartisan recommendation of
ought to pass on hb 1021 which for the
record we opposed um appears we've lost
that
but that would modify rsa 674 colon
75 or i guess add a new provision there
that says no zoning ordinance or site
plan review
regulations shall prohibit regulate
or restrict the use of land or
structures for religious purposes
and it goes on from there um but that
may have the same effect as this bill um
i haven't analyzed the two
um together but i wanted to point that
out to the committee since i know um
it's the policy of the general court to
try to coordinate legislation where
possible
i'm happy to take questions
sure
um
yeah if it turn if it turns out that
the
other bill is broader
and um does in fact
do the same thing as i'm trying to do
here then i'd be
i'd be okay with withdrawing this one
and just letting the other one do its
thing
any other commentary or questions
thank you seeing none thanks uh
match grace
it looks like we're out of speakers
so i'm going to close the hearing
on
hb 1219.
okay we're close to being done and
you'll know why in a second
next on our calendar is um
here we go
hb
one two two three
relative to meeting attendance
requirements for elected members of the
budget committee and school board
i'm going to open the uh
the opportunity for questions and
comments
but
i
i see we're starting to have
deteriorating weather and i want to cut
this short and recess this
so does anybody have any comments
about hb 1223
with the understanding that
on monday when we convene i'll
end the recess and reopen it for more
comments
yes uh representative power thank you mr
chair i have a question
so will this bill be introduced on
monday or not
uh i
it could be uh with a with if there are
more people here to
carry that function out if not one of us
can introduce the bill
representative wrong your comment
well i just wanted to say that i think
that a lot of municipalities already
have attendance requirements
for budget committee and and school
board
and i was just wondering why towns were
omitted from this
and village districts
that that was just mine
i think you're right
i know in my town
if you don't show up for a
certain number of meetings in a row you
kicked off the uh
of the committee of
i don't know about the
the
school board but
they might have their own special rules
any other further comments before we uh
end the session
all right
yes representative so uh so this would
be the way to remove an elected official
well i'm more concerned with the elected
not the appointed yes i i think that
removing electorate of elect elected
officials is a very delicate
process
and i would uh think that this would
have to have
a little more research done on it to see
if
what we're saying here can actually be
done
with regard to
removing an elected member
of the school board or a budget
committee
yes
she said it's discriminate
discriminatory against people who have
an illness
yes representative wrong
yeah another question i would have for
monday is that
it says
she'll be considered to have created a
vacancy
so i'd want i guess that is removal from
office if it's creating a vacancy or is
it adding another person
um
yeah so it is just following up on what
representative tripp said
i would consider that very seriously if
we're taking away a position that the
people have elected
um because
there could there could have been an
illness or surgery or what there could
be a lot of reasons thank you
further questions comments
all right seeing none uh
i'm going to
recess
hb 12 23 and we'll take that up on
monday morning
in addition to the other bills
those are all bills they're not uh
executive sessions on monday
so thank you all and drive carefully
let's
of the start
it's starting to rain and we're supposed
to get freezing rain this afternoon and
snow tonight and tomorrow
depending on
where you are
in the state
get in that way
my
so you're going to check with uh curtis
if we
you